welcome back to the channel this is part
two of our q a and i split these up into
two sessions because it was getting too
long if you haven't checked out part one
i'll leave it right here i was really
surprised at the reaction to the first q
a i thought it wouldn't get a very good
response because it wasn't based on a
specific topic
i was wrong and uh thank you all for
writing in and sharing your feedback it
really warmed my heart yeah part two
let's start
so first question would you ever want to
practice architecture in a different
country i probably wouldn't want to
practice architecture as in like start
my own firm anywhere else but i would
love to gain international experience
working at different firms in different
countries and
if i'm gonna do it i probably have to do
it in the next couple of years before i
get too
old
and kind of have to like settle down and
have kids and stuff like that i always
felt super limited in time because like
you only have so many years if you
really want to grow and learn something
from a firm like i think you
the minimum amount of time
should be like a year
because that's probably like the
shortest amount of time that a project
can go from like start to finish like in
your entire career you might actually
only get a chance to work at a handful
of firms
so
the
further you get
you kind of have to be a little bit more
selective in where you work also there's
like another part of me that really
wants to gain like local knowledge and
expertise
and establish myself here in vancouver
realistically if i go somewhere else i
won't be as valuable because i don't
know the local building code
and i won't have any industry
connections
and like my entire architecture
portfolio is here i think i definitely
want to try to finish one or two more
buildings here and maybe decide where i
want to do my last
work experience i haven't really
seriously started thinking about it so
if you guys have any ideas please let me
know okay this is the easy one rich and
lonely or poor and happy come on guys
obviously rich and lonely
just kidding
hello darkness smile poor and happy yeah
okay next question is a very interesting
question
as a non-architect what are the things i
should know so that i'm not taken
advantage by an architect i guess this
question depends on
whose point of view you're asking from
you could be asking from a client's
point of view or an engineer's point of
view or an interior designer
or a product rep from a client's
perspective you're right there's
probably times where it's possible that
you could feel taken advantage of
and probably one of the scenarios could
be
you were convinced to spend more money
in this particular area there are
probably a few things that architects
have expertise in
that gives them power over other people
which is the building code
in a lot of cases you kind of need to
take the architect's word for it
and unfortunately there's very few ways
you can kind of check for yourself
whether
or not they're telling the truth well
they're bound by the law to tell the
truth but i mean the code is very
cryptic
you won't be able to really
look into it yourself i've seen
situations because i worked at an
interior design firm before where the
interior designers would hire an outside
architect to go over the code and stamp
the drawings i remember there were
certain design things we wanted to do
that would require the architect to go
kind of above and beyond the code
standards and he
basically just told us that
it wasn't possible based on my
experience with the city i
like having read and studied the code
knew that it was a possibility but
the architect just didn't want to spend
the time to argue with the city about it
because i had very little experience and
this outside architect had lots of
experience we followed his way
so
code that's the one thing the architect
could also try to
trick you with function architects
sometimes use function as an excuse to
introduce a formal or aesthetic element
to the project
that may end up costing you more money
for example the architect might
introduce polish concrete as the most
durable and long-lasting flooring option
but there's also
other very durable materials that don't
cost as much they could also
like introduce a really
intricate ceiling panel system for your
entire ceiling for acoustic absorption
but
um it might just be because they want to
get that look all that being said most
architects just want what's best for you
because they
live in constant fear of their clients
not liking something that they design
even if you think they're trying to take
advantage of you it's for your own good
and it's kind of like when your parents
trick you into eating your vegetable
by mixing it into
a sugary cereal
yeah no that sounds terrible
like when they mix it in a meatball
pasta that's probably a better
comparison since getting fully qualified
has your role change for the better or
worse in the uk architects have a more
project manager role and get to do less
design work which i see as a downside so
far i haven't seen any downsides to
getting licensed in terms of the work
that i'm doing at my firm i'm managing
my own projects and yeah i do have to do
more admin and coordination work it's
true
less time is spent on pure design or
concept but i think that's just the
natural result of managing your own
project and for me uh right now i just
want to know everything that's going on
in my project because that's how you can
kind of turn the design into real life i
think a lot of people have really great
designs but where it goes wrong is kind
of a lot of the times in the execution
so i want to know like exactly where the
sprinklers are going and where all the
ducts are going what level of sheen
we're using for the floors you kind of
do that by being involved in the whole
process
and by being involved in the spec
writing
and the actual documentation of the
design for me personally i'm just more
interested in the holistic
process of making the building and like
the design come to life yeah for me i
haven't seen too many downsides do you
have any recommendations for a high
schooler
to do now that could support them as a
future architecture student i would say
go visit a lot of
well-known buildings in your
neighborhood
and start taking photos and start
sketching and
start like building a library of
buildings in your mind and in your
computer
that you can kind of pull from i think
having a big library of projects that
you can reference is
very important and it's a really big
asset to you as an architect so the
earlier you can start doing that the
better because when you're designing
something let's say you have an idea for
a ceiling you kind of want to be able to
show how it's actually been done in real
life um i was wondering how you were
able to find the balance between sleep
school and social life during your time
in architecture school
if you were even able to lull
if i could tell you one thing that i do
and have done pretty consistently from
school to now i try to give myself about
an hour for something on a saturday to
kind of schedule my week
and i try to yeah create a rough
schedule of what i want to do
every single day at the beginning of
each day when i'm sitting down to make
my schedule for the week um before like
putting any tasks or times i just
try to make a list of like literally
everything i have to do i just dump
everything on a list i call this like my
inbox and once i finish that i kind of
go through the list and actually try to
figure out what needs to get done
that week if there's like things that
can wait those things just kind of stay
in the inbox and i review it again like
a week later when i'm putting those
tasks into my weeks i try to chunk like
similar tasks together so that i'm not
switching from doing emails to doing
drawings to doing phone calls like when
i have a bunch of phone calls to make
then i just make that all into a list
and i do all the phone calls all at the
same time switching back and forth and
this has been documented
switching back and forth is
a huge waste of time and it takes out a
lot of energy out of you and it also
takes a lot of time for you to get back
to what you're doing so yeah i try to
schedule similar tasks into the same
chunk of the day and every morning like
i said i try to spend around 15 minutes
to just like try to figure out what i'm
gonna do that day as things come
throughout the week things
shift
from the schedule that i'd made and
that's like totally fine
generally give myself like
a time limit for doing certain tasks so
if i need to finish doing floor plans
i'll give myself like two hours usually
like my days never go as i planned it
but
having that time limit and the schedule
just helps me know where i am compared
to my schedule
and like what i should be reaching for
how are you earning money during
architecture school to cut costs on the
buying of materials printing and all
since there's less time to spare for
ourselves when i was in school in the
first four years i wasn't working but i
worked as a ta and ra when i was in my
master's basically i think the thing
that made the biggest difference for me
was that like actually checked out the
cost of tuition for all the schools that
i was applying for for my master's my
decision to go back to the school that i
went for my bachelor's was like
primarily based on the fact that i got
like a full scholarship that's really
gonna make the biggest difference like
you saving money here and there isn't
gonna make that much of a difference oh
i also worked as a
assistant at the department of
architecture
um so i was helping them like organize
events and
figure out like the guest list of people
whenever we had shows and stuff that was
a great gig because the work was right
in my school and all i had to do was
just go from my studio
down to the office i think if i had to
go
somewhere else to work i don't think i
could have done it my course load was
pretty intensive yeah like try to get a
position in the architecture school or
at least in your university next
question is related so how was the
process of paying back your debt while
working in the architecture field
so like i mentioned before i made sure
to check the tuition cost of the schools
that i was gonna go to before i even
applied because i think that's the
single biggest
factor in you paying back your student
loans i know that there are some schools
in the states that's like ridiculously
expensive and there's some schools in
the in europe that's free i really
don't know how much of a difference
the school makes because in the end like
you're coming out with a degree and
in the end
everyone can go through the same
licensure process check the
cost of tuition first and see if you can
get any grants or
scholarships or bursaries yeah like i
said i worked part-time during my
bachelor's and my master's and between
that i took a year off to work once i
graduated my master's and like actually
started interning at a firm i was lucky
that i could live at my mom's house for
those couple of years and just like
focus on paying back my student loans
yeah i just took on any kind of work i
could i did overtime over time pay is
like 1.5 where it was at my firm i did
lots and lots of like freelance work i
did renderings i did architectural
drawings
and if you're an intern there's like
very little regulations against you
doing side work that was how i was able
to pay back my student loans in a
relatively quick time okay next question
could you recommend a book that covers
architectural construction drawings for
a recent grad
or a pro architect for reference
hold on one second
this is the book that you're going to
want to buy
building construction illustrated by
francis ching
and i used this book when i was
studying for my exacts i still use this
book now
it covers like everything
and anything from
site to building construction to
materials
and this is a really really really good
starting point for
architecture students or experienced
architects okay next question
how many projects do you work on as an
architect
multiple or one at a time
so right now i'm working on just one
project but it's not uncommon to work on
multiple projects at a time personally i
would prefer to work on one project at a
time so that i can just focus on that
but that's just not the reality of how
the business works i think when you
become a partner or
when you're put in a more senior
position
you might actually oversee multiple
projects and
not actually be involved in doing the
project for me ideally in the future i
would still like to be like involved in
the project and not just like manage
them for me i just have to design my
path like that and if that's what you're
interested in too you should
really try to design your career like
that okay next question
what can the architectural industry do
to support more
vpoc and women i think
at a
organizational level you can start by
creating systems and structures with
requirements for attendance from bpoc
and women for example
the city of vancouver
and
most municipalities have what's called a
urban design panel
which is made up of 13 members
representing like the
six groups which is like the architects
engineers
landscape architects um there's a person
from the development industry
planner there's an artist
and we basically sit down and review the
development
we basically sit down and review the
development proposals in the city
and make recommendations for it
and this year
they made it mandatory that 50 percent
of the udp has to be women
and historically until now
the six architects on the panel have
been all
older white males and usually like
principles of affirms
and
of course like you still have to like
submit your resume and be approved to be
on the panel but with this new mandate
you're forcing more women into the
discussion
places like the udp has always been
this like old boys club so female
architects even if they were principals
they
would feel like
why would i spend my time there you know
but by just having this mandate sets the
tone it's always kind of a way of
forcing diversity in our in our city
building another thing is i think having
a firm culture that's providing fair and
equal treatment for
women who have babies i heard lots of
female architects that
when they said they were gonna go on mat
leave
they were not regarded as the future of
the firm anymore
even after they put in years of their
lives into the firm
so that's wrong
and that's a huge loss
for the industry and for the firm
because when this happens women just
like leave the profession and go off and
do other things and i think it's not
just an architecture but like society in
general has to be better at
accommodating working moms and if they
want us to if they want working moms to
continue working there should be proper
systems in place to kind of smooth that
transition i will be doing more vlogs
anytime soon
yes i will
and
will you be keeping a regular upload
schedule
yes i will
and in fact i am aiming to do
one or if i'm ambitious
two videos a week stay tuned for that
what made you want to start a youtube
channel i actually answered this in my
very first q a video so
uh you can check that out here and the
next question is um
how can i grow more in the architecture
community on youtube like any other
industry making high quality content
give value
and give out free value and insights
that you're not going to be able to find
anywhere else
and make videos consistently
another thing is you should try to learn
how to edit your own videos develop your
own style and then hire an editor so
that you can tell them exactly how you
want it to be edited
and you know exactly like how long it's
gonna take how in your opinion do you
think canadian architecture compares to
the rest of the world
i'm actually gonna make a separate video
on this so stay tuned
have you or do you intend to work on
international projects i have not worked
on an international project yet but it
is one of the reasons why i joined the
firm that i'm at right now which is a uk
firm
with their satellite office in vancouver
and so
the uk base definitely does tons of
projects all over europe and the world
there's quite a lot of crossover between
um our office so
definitely hopefully i'll get to work on
some international projects what's your
favorite architecture place
since you said place not a particular
building i'm gonna say venice is my
favorite place i love going there and
just like walking around the labyrinth
and alleys without like any particular
destination or like looking at the map
and you're just like transported into a
completely different world and
it's quiet and mysterious
and i just love that feeling of getting
lost in the city thank you for joining
guys for this part two of the q a i hope
you found it interesting or at least
entertaining if you are interested in
some of my other videos that actually
have a topic i have videos on
presentation techniques videos where i
talk about creativity i'll leave it in
the description if you want to check it
out if you have any follow-up questions
or further comments just leave it in the
comment section if you are interested in
seeing more videos
and you are not subscribed to the
channel please subscribe i have some
good content coming out every week
possibly even twice a week if you
enjoyed this video please give me a
thumbs up and i'll see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]